elle a dit la vérité moi elle m'a
prévenue avait envoyé par
l'intermédiaire d'une personne des
messages et des enregistrements même de
discussions qu'elle a eues avec dana et
qui voulait faire du mal à carla donc à
la vue cette bienveillance je peux pas
lui même franchement on peut pas dire le
contraire
maintenant de les envoyer dans une
période où moi j'étais en train de faire
ma grand mère est gravement malade donc
c'est vrai que j'ai pas calculer ce
message et puis j'en reçois énormément
des messages on dit vaut candidats ils
ont fait ça etc etc
et du coup ben je les ai eus on va dire
dix quinze jours après et je l'avais
transmis à kevin
à ce moment là c'est évident que le mari
vilain mari de carla donc là dessus a
dit la vérité est effectivement dana et
d'après ce que j'ai compris est une
voyante fausse voyante qui faisait appel
à guarda pour faire des choses que ward
a est une vraie voyante alors alors
d'analystes ont voulu faire on s'arrête
deux minutes sur danahy parce que
dimanche soir sur snapshot magali vous
avait expliqué ne pas connaître d'anaïs
ouimet et pourtant depuis quelques jours
il ya une ancienne publication danet qui
ressort sur les réseaux sociaux dans
laquelle on voit quelqu'un qui bourses
ont participé à une soirée d'halloween
chez la voyante mais il ya des gens qui
ont dit que c'était pas vous ouais donc
c'est pas vous absolument pas mais
jamais vu dana alors j'ai essayé plein
de gens qui disent non vous la
connaissiez donc la connaissance donc
c'est alors cette personne ne m'a
contacté deux fois elle m'a contacté une
signe de deuil
dana et une croix en 2019 pour j'ai
retrouvé ça dans mes messages instagram
que je n'ai jamais ouvert donc je les
données à la prod pour me demander de
faire de la télé réalité
si je pouvais l'intégrer dans une
télé-réalité d'accord rien de grave là
dessus non mais bon ça prouve qu'elle
voulait quand même se coller au co
candidats téléralité vous devrez donc
s'est incrusté dans le milieu
téléréalité et ensuite elle nous a
contacté mon service commercial donc pas
moi directement pour faire de la
promotion via notre agence nous on avait
soumis à la rpp donc l'autorité qui
régule les publicités et la publicité
si on avait demandé est-ce qu'on a droit
mais les sionistes y avait plein de
plein de gens de chez vous qui avez fait
des placements de produits pour d'année
mais ce n'est pas passé par agence et ça
je le dis ouvertement il n'y a aucun
candidat passée par là mais parce que
nous on avait refusé le partenariat
l'onf et sol ils ont prié et j'ai donné
là
le screen du message de refus qu'on
avait envoyé donc le service juridique
avait refusé j'ai donné le message
j'ai donné la lettre de l'erp et qui
nous déconseillé de le faire qu'ils ont
droit à travailler or votre agence alors
normalement non d'accord donc voilà
certains mais attention sur le compte de
dada et il n'ya que 40 % qui sont mon
âge enfin il y en a 60 % qui sont
d'autres agents dire quand même et ceux
de votre agence vous leur avez rien dit
mais en vrai moins de dix ans n'ont pas
été rémunérés qui ont été invités à
cette soirée et ses rangs mais disney
vont payer une consultation à ce que
c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas est-ce
que c'est pas un mais c'est pas un
échange et à leur fait des travaux il
poste un truc alors moi ils me disent
qu'ils ont payé la consultation après je
vais être honnête avec vous je n'en sais
rien maintenant en tout cas tout ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce n'est pas passé par
l' agence est de toute manière quoiqu'il
on peut c'est impossible qu'on puisse
dire que c'est passé en deux ans que ce
n'est pas passé par l' agence gilles
verdez magali je trouve que vous évincer
un peu vite les liens possibles que vous
auriez avec dana alors vous nous dites
que non mais laissez moi je veux finir
quand même la photo elle est quand même
très troublant djeuga sur sur la photo
que considérer la montre et moi je j'en
ai eus on m'a envoyé des centaines
chaque fois j'ai examiné excusez moi
mais sur la photo pour moi c'est vous
oui oui alors c'est votre choisi non
mais écoutez je vais vous répondre à ça
à cette soirée là il y avait si vous
regardez d'autres sur l'instinct g de
dana et j'espère qu'elle ne supprimera
pas donc fait vite pour les screen et il
ya la photo de vivian aussi un candidat
téléralité dit je sais pas non mais
c'est pas ça c'est que comme le soir du
31 octobre parce que c'est une soirée
halloween 2019 donc c'est cette soirée
70 semaines j'ai regardé mes messages et
j'ai eu j'ai retrouvé et heureusement et
je vous les et screen et est amené j'ai
fait la vidéo pour qu'on voit bien les
dates comme ça on peut pas dire que
c'est un montage
la vidéo dit vian qui a filmé cette
personne en m'envoyant regarde j'ai
trouvé ton sosie et je voulais cela dit
si vous pouvez diffuser ouais j'ai
répondu tu alors on va la vidéo jardé
tombe bien il avait répondu sa passion
magali vers l'intérêt que me garder je
suis choqué par contre il aurait
apparemment donc c'est une fille que tu
n'as pas tu n'as pas su mais apparemment
ce qu'on va dire donc voilà enfin que
c'est l'enfant caché mais c'est vrai que
là vous ressemble mais c'est oui mais
moi je suis pour rien et c'est vrai que
les gens enfin et cette photo et c'est
réel c'est réel c'est à dire
qu'heureusement est la chose qui m'a
sauvée parce que regarder commune une
polémique peut aller vite et regarder
comment on peut accuser quelqu'un très
vite
heureusement que vivian m'avait envoyé
cette vidéo est bien ces dates et voyez
en bon alors ça ça non mais là on a bien
vu c'est vrai que voilà donc gilles
verdez voilà mes bonnes questions parce
qu'à plein de gens qui se posent à
quelqu'un donc c'est normal d'y répondre